[Music]
[Applause]
Bob Costas Hall of Fame broadcaster was
on the call 25 years ago tonight we
thought Michael Jordan's final shot and
Bob is uh said that that was not exactly
a push off by Michael Jordan that's like
a Mater D showing you to your table Bob
I still I that I've never been shown to
my table by a major day where I nearly
fell over so I'm gonna I'm gonna
disagree with uh that description yeah
but Dan he wasn't falling because of the
very light push he was already stumbling
because because Michael had faked him
out of his sneakers that's kind of what
happened if that happens in the second
quarter of a regular season game nobody
even disputes No One turns and says hey
wait that was a push-off
nothing it's because of where it
happened who it happened to one of the
most iconic moments in in the history of
sports forget about the NBA if Utah has
a gripe and they do in that game there
was no replay then in the first half
Howard Eisley hit a three that was waved
off as a shot clock violation and we had
it on NBC it's out of his hands before
the clock hits zero so that's three
points taken away from Utah later in the
game Ron Harper hits a two that did not
beat the shot clock and it was allowed
that's a five-point swing of course when
people say it's like oh well in fact I
was thrown out trying to steal second
base on the next guy homers it would
have been a two-run homer that's not
necessarily logical because if the
circumstances are different maybe what
happened subsequently plays out
differently but in a game that was that
close you take five points away from
Utah they have a case that maybe they
could have played a game seven in Utah
if United later
so go back to the play that's forgotten
and it's equally as impressive as Jordan
Steele and Carl Malone that led to the
game-winning shot
yeah he's being guarded by Rodman and uh
according to Michael's subsequent
testimony
um he came around from the side and
Malone never saw him Michael left his
guy along the Baseline and
Malone is preoccupied with Rodman and
Michael comes from the other side and
slaps it away
yeah and then that led to what five
seconds ago where he hits the jumper
um as you guys were game planning after
he makes the steal and then there's a
timeout I believe and then what is being
discussed by you guys uh in in the
anticipate because we've seen Steve Kerr
hit a game-winning shot John Paxson hit
a game-winning shot is everybody in
unison that this is going to be Michael
Jordan taking the shot
yeah pretty much because when he stole a
ball uh he then has it and no one else
touched it and when you think about it
what's surprising about that Pippin's
hobbling around with a bad back he's
Michael Jordan he's going to take that
shot he didn't pass it to anybody he had
it the whole time he took it out of out
of the back court into the front Court
made the shot over Russell but when he
makes the shot there's 5.2 seconds left
so even though the Bulls are up by one
whatever you say uh the possibility that
this is a championship winning shot the
possibility that's the last shot Michael
Jordan will ever take in his NBA career
which briefly turned out to be true
until he came back with the Wizards for
an encore uh that's a possibility but
it's certainly not a certainty because
there's still five seconds left and you
talk at score and Stockton got a decent
look
um Harper was guarding him as I remember
uh had a hand in his face he got a
decent look and as I remember it hit the
back iron but it was kind of On Target
so if that goes in they play a game
seven on on Utah's home floor take us
back and I apologize I thought for some
reason when Jordan made the steal that
they would have called a timeout then
but no you know no no time out no that's
interesting strategy but you know
strategy always helps you when you have
Michael Jordan we're talking to Bob
Costas who was on the call let's go back
to the flu game what did you know
prior to the game as you know Michael's
condition and why he was in that
condition you know I didn't work the 97
playoffs uh I had I had taken a Hiatus
courtesy of my my good friend and Patron
uh dick Ebersole so Marv's doing the
game
um and I think Hannah Storm's doing
doing the premise of course I watched
every minute of it uh and I find out
later and it's a big part of the Last
Dance you know did he have the flu or
did he have food poisoning and if you've
ever had food poisoning Dan which I have
had a couple of times
that's as CL as bad as you can feel
knowing for a fact that you will not die
you know yeah so it was food poisoning I
think it's even worse than if he had
merely had quote the flu
when you think of Jordan's career
it's almost like it it grows it's like
Babe Ruth it it tends to grow yeah you
know metastasizes they're just what is
it about that like Mickey Mantle's
Legacy there's so many of these athletes
where
if you may not remember them being as
great as they were in the moment but
then as we kind of move farther and
farther away does LeBron get the benefit
of this do you think the way Michael
Jordan has
no not as much through no fault of
LeBron's you can make a very strong
statistical case for LeBron uh in a
LeBron Michael uh comparison and LeBron
discounting centers because I've always
felt we've talked about this before
they're in a separate category how do
you compare will to Russell or Kareem or
Elijah one or a healthy Bill Walton or
whomever how do you Shack how do you
compare them to forwards and guards but
LeBron never comes out these days any
worse than number two behind Jordan in
that comparison but what LeBron does not
have is as many iconic moments that are
replayed almost on a loop and are in
everyone's imagination including those
who didn't see it firsthand going all
the way back to the game-winning shot
for North Carolina in 82 against
Georgetown and then being the
centerpiece of the first Dream Team and
then all those postseason moments most
of them in the finals but even the shot
on Elo in an earlier round of the
playoffs against the Cavaliers so many
of those moments and the iconic
commercials be like Mike and just
thinking about the game we're talking
about now that is still the highest
rated game in NBA history and the
ratings for those games during the 80s
and 90s on CBS Bird magic and then uh
I'm sorry in during the 80s on CBS then
in the 90s on NBC the ratings for those
games generally dwarf the ratings that
uh NBA games get now and many of those
NBA games are on cable rather than
over-the-air broadcast television and
that will diminish not objectively but
in terms of the public imagination that
doesn't just diminish LeBron in
comparison to Jordan or Byrd or magic it
will diminish Nicola jokic it will
diminish Jimmy Butler or whomever you
want to name through no fault of their
own it's like Michael is Neil Armstrong
he's the first on the moon and everybody
else may land there but Mike was the
first there to plant the flag Bob will
be doing an hour-long interview with
Albert Pujols later today for MLB
Network and uh air 2B determined there a
couple of baseball questions were well
into the pitch clock uh how do you feel
I think in general all the changes have
been tremendously successful I've had a
few players and managers tell me that
they think 15 seconds with no one on
base is a little quick and they'd prefer
a uniform 20 seconds nobody on and with
men on base a uniform 20 seconds but I
haven't heard anybody dispute the
general idea that the pitch clock
Banning shifts the two pick-off throws
per at bat which lets our base runner be
a bit more adventurous it's nearly
unanimous that this is not just okay but
it's a rousing success the A's moving to
Vegas does Vegas take the A's out of the
oak they're taking the A's out of
Oakland but do they take the nickname
well if they keep the nickname then the
A's become the first team in MLB history
to have the same name in four different
locations break breaking a tie they had
with the Braves the Braves and the A's
are the only ones with three the Braves
were in Boston in Milwaukee and now for
a long time in Atlanta and the A's were
in Philadelphia Kansas City Oakland and
now perhaps in Vegas but last night I'm
sure you saw this Dan and maybe you
mentioned it earlier uh this morning the
the A's had a a reverse boycott night or
whatever they were protest last night
yeah fans fans came out and the idea was
let's fill the stadium or at least have
much larger crowds than we've generally
been drawing to show that there's
support there if we had reason to have
faith in the team and then throughout
the game they're chanting sell the team
meanwhile this team that was threatening
the worst record of all time for a
season like making the the 62 Mets look
like a juggernaut now they've won seven
straight so go figure and the angels are
still in the playoff race which means as
we get closer to the trade deadline if
you're tempted to trade shoheiotani it
makes it even harder because you're in
the playoff race uh what do you think
happens with Otani I I don't think they
trade him and if they were to trade him
it would make the Hall that the gnats
got for sending Juan Soto to San Diego
looked like a pittance I mean you'd have
to empty your entire farm system all
your top prospects plus throw in some
players that can be useful right now uh
I just don't I don't see that happening
plus there's only a handful of teams
that are realistically in the mix if he
decides to leave the angels and sign
with some other team as a free agent so
why would those teams want to empty
their farm system if the real test is
going to come as to how much money
they're willing to pay him on a 10-year
deal or whatever it is uh to sign a
contract with them and some team that
has no chance to to sign him beyond that
time I don't think is going to roll the
dice and pay the price it would take for
a mid-season trade just to have a shot
at a second or third wild card spot just
doesn't seem to add up great to talk to
you as always Bob thanks for joining us
thanks a lot Dan that's Bob Costas Hall
of Fame broadcaster working for MLB
Network and uh was the play-by-play
voice of the NBA on NBC from
1997 through 1999 2000 season and uh e
me I thought when Jordan made this steal
that there was a timeout and Phil
Jackson let him go in transition and
then he hits the jumper there